retailers are gearing up for what could
be the biggest u.s. online shopping day
in history Cyber Monday is expected that
generates six point six billion dollars
in sales that's nearly 17 percent
increase over last year 58 percent of
adults plan to make an online purchase
today on average each will spend about
270 dollars
Donita copal is inside Amazon
Fulfillment Center in Robbinsville New
Jersey with how the retail giant is
preparing for all of those clicks Toni
good morning good morning cyber monday
is the first Monday after Thanksgiving
it's a day when people get back to
shopping online and when they do
facilities like this one fly into motion
Amazon has 14 miles of conveyor belts
right here alone
this one is sending out some of the very
first packages of the holiday rush
Amazon customers worldwide bought more
than 64 million items on Cyber Monday
last year that's seven hundred and forty
items per second this time around a
surge in shoppers clicking their
smartphones will keep the employees
inside this mammoth fulfillment center
just as busy according to Amazon
spokeswoman Lorie torgussen last year
more than 70 percent of Amazon customers
purchased orders through their mobile
devices and this year we're already
seeing Thanksgiving Day was one of the
most popular mobile shopping days of the
year many shoppers didn't wait for cyber
monday deals they got a head start on
Black Friday consumers spent a record
five billion dollars the day after
Thanksgiving enticed by deep discounts
on computers televisions and toys both
Black Friday and Cyber Monday have been
diluted the scene at senior editor Dan
Ackerman says cyber monday deals often
continued into December but consumers
still need to research products and be
savvy about their purchases things that
seemed too good to be true like
big-screen televisions that are you know
just incredibly inexpensive just a
couple of hundred dollars because
frankly they're probably not the brand
you want the increasing popularity of
online shopping is also putting pressure
on traditional retailers says economics
professor David Clark I would suspect
that the number of jobs that are created
as a result of you know growth in
companies like Amazon
is surpassed by the number of jobs that
are lost in these traditional
bricks-and-mortar
types of establishments Amazon which has
hired more than 120,000 seasonal
employees to work it at 75 fulfillment
centers across the country doesn't
believe cyber monday will necessarily
lead to brick-and-mortar stores going
out of business I think there's a lot of
players in retail and it'll be there's
room for a lot of winners this facility
is also highly automated as you can see
from this scanner but Amazon says that
just creates more work for their holiday
employees more work for the people who
are rushing to meet that demand Gayle
thank you very much Tony the couple
makes you want to say what's in those
packages over there Amazon has really
changed the model for house it's really
incredible I still like going to the
store and trying stuff on but that seems
to be a dinosaur now people just like to
get it get it home and try it on Vanessa
I am yeah including the including the
fryer for the out in the deeper Amazon
came straight from Amazon they made it
easy yeah there you go
I see thank you Tony to copal